Hey
rejects so I'm Greg I'm John how you do
it listen for a while now since April
2017 J M Villante has been one of our
top patrons ever even like this was
during the time we were trying to figure
out what the hell we were even doing on
patreon what what was consistent content
to provide how do we have a top patron
so he's been he's been a huge supporter
for such a long time he barely asks for
anything in return but for the past
couple months one of the few things he's
asked for is that we do a reaction to
one of his favorite movies the classic
film Nosferatu which is full of all
kinds of audio love oh yeah and I've
actually never seen it you seen it
before a long time ago right now this is
one of my favorite like classic movement
okay however mind it's been a long time
since I was gonna try to make this seem
like oh it's fresh freezed I mean I've
never cease what's the mouse for ah damn
speak English guy have to rehearse ever
been a good amount of time anyway so
we're gonna watch this it'll probably
turn into like a commentary track
so yeah let's you know I know sometimes
we do reactions but if you think for the
watch of lungs we tend to talk more yeah
as opposed to like a trailer we work
well you know it's long-form I feel like
you know you got a mystery science at a
little time just to anyone else does oh
yeah well we're also gonna do that for
the webcam because it's a movie and this
camera does cut it make it hard to sync
but there'll be a timer at the bottom
for you guys to watch along so you might
hear me count out loud so I know where
to sink it so yeah guys let's do it
all right guys we're making it darker
cuz it's a movie
spoons let's get to it alright guys
watching from Amazon our twenty minutes
coming your way
boo
yeah here we go uno dos tres one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven yes don't distribute this Ruby
unlawfully 14 15 here we go
should be synced fingers crossed
f Gary great record yeah I got to tell
you guys something I have never seen a
silent film oh this will be fun even the
artists I feel like this is don't quote
me but this might be a good one to jump
in on have you ever seen a shadow of the
vampire yeah that's a great there's a
lot of dialogue in it yeah but that
movie is actually about the making of
this yeah yeah yeah where they explore
if Max Schreck is a real vampire and
that's all true I didn't know he's
called Count Dracula yeah I think it
changes depending on which like print
you get cuz I think some of them have
them called Count Orlok or something
like that
so this is the actual OG Dracula yeah I
think they ran into like legal trouble
or something with the estate of Bram
Stoker being like this is Dracula yeah
guys made Dracula or I may have my facts
all wrong but that's I mean if he's
called Count Dracula and it's a similar
setup I'd imagine that it's really
probably right to a legal lawsuit yeah
from the diary of Johanna to vilius Abel
history was in a city of Bremen not
straw to that name alone can chill the
blood Nosferatu was he who brought the
plague defragment in 1838 I wish it
would release just a concept album of
all horror
I've long sought the causes of that
terrible epidemic in founders origins
climaxing mr. Fisher huh can't climax
huh it's good see what you did there
Wow I forgot how old this movie I was
like a look into history here when it's
really weird to watch it it's like a
completely digital setting kitty cats
haven't involved
so this is visual storytelling mm-hmm I
want this all explained to me okay hello
just walking Phoenix's The Joker I mean
there's definitely a little bit that man
who laughs in there which is actually a
classic I've never seen
my own those look really nice for him
and [ __ ] yanking now you will blow me
okay
meanwhile if I could watch silent movies
with this much commentary I think I'd
have a good time yeah I'm happy you
can't escape destiny no oh wow that's a
that's an imposing statement to make on
some random guy he's gonna die the agent
Renfield was a strange man and there
were unpleasant rumors about him the old
man was agent Renfield I believe so yeah
and that's a definite dracula character
hey no ed as a resume dad is it the same
for so many years dudes born old like a
pagoda is this Renfield I think so
was this sort of horn look like back
then yes he's not strange you just the
first porn attic trap the load in that
room curtly be bored all day
here is an important letter from
Transylvania come through Kela wishes to
buy a house in our city oh that's bad
there there goes the neighborhood it's a
good opportunity for you Harker the
count is rich and free with his money
free with his money yeah does that mean
I'm making it rain that's drac you gots
the modern-day Dracula we deserve yeah
you'll have a marvelous journey and
young as you are what matter if it costs
you some pain or even a little blood oh
[Laughter]
that's not for shadowing do they know
he's a vampire of course if this was a
modern day sauna phone they would have
underlined that word blood and put it in
red t ha ha we have a business plan
it's like a ride the cam
well it's kind of easy to get lost in
this
it's hypnotic in its own way yeah taking
watching a documentary well yeah the
other thing too is like everything is so
hyper tangible like you know nothing's
been replaced the house facing yours
that she's here is this guy working for
Dracula I'm starting to think yeah
says things it's been a little while
since I've caught the fire leave it once
my young friend and don't be frightened
if people speak of Transylvania as the
land of phantoms Oh Billy Zane's out
there dude
he totally knows a dragon all right
woman we're moving for a vampire more
money I may be away for several months
Nina Redfield is sending me to some lost
corner of the Companions car our
Guardians Oh stupid wonder how long it
took for people to do their hair back
then Wow must be awesome to just tell
your woman that I'm leaving for several
months bye
and I'm super excited and not gonna miss
you at all oh that's not all travelling
was just like I'll see you eventually
bye I don't care maybe I'll catch you
later this is just a fact of life rest
yeah bring that Passport
Oh passionate lover oh maybe one before
the road Hawker left knee no it is
girlfriend's Westenra ha hey why you see
that accent I'm supposed to enjoy it
when you do that what it does tickle me
when you do that was just my Jamaican
accent yeah no one's trying yeah don't
worry ya know ting bad will happen to me
nothing will happen well do what do you
[ __ ] sucker here all damn improv you
damn they love each other
Wow I can't we consistently kisses her
do they intentionally make the picture
all jumpy no it's just happens that's
just the quality just early cameras be
here early came from relayed to relay
through the dust raised by the stages
Harker hurried on Wow or they filmed
this Louisiana Atlanta great tax breaks
as what when people just throw stuff off
stagecoaches way why is he leaving just
trying to sell it to Count Dracula I
guess oh yeah he's like come spend your
money here he's a flunky for old
Renfield's creepy plan just this guy
doesn't do anything half-assed quickly
I'll be ready beats Castle the
transition from that level of enthusiasm
and laughter to imperative statement
dinner quickly I should already be a
great time but seriously you guys I
should have been that guy's mustache
you have no facial hair were you you
don't trust people like you around these
parts you must not leave now the evil
spirits become all-powerful after dark
that's a good one yeah okay I'll do that
thanks for the advice ooh
hyena where they give an actual dialogue
to say back then or they just moving you
know that's a great question I bet a lip
reader could just be like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah hey I mean if ya [ __ ] I will hurry
on if at least shadow the vampire is any
indication like there are a couple
scenes in that movie where they're
rolling
yeah and Shrek is saying like other
stuff so it's totally possible I would
imagine well if there was a video that
was appropriate at this one
came for the the right video today Oh
buddy what if they're the ASPCA on set
for this wonder how they you know came
up with this organ score there's like
hey man just sit down and play for 70
minutes just make it up make it sinister
just like she has candles so I can see
myself masturbate
ah so much brighter in here so I should
read pasta I love reading the book of
the vampires perfect that I brought my
fictional novel have foreign met count
Dracula's just so I could think about
other things
say for I meet this human take my mind
off business that the first Nosferatu
Nosferatu that's a thing I should be
able to break that name down nos is a
type of thing you put in a car okay fur
is a type of animal there's an animal's
skin thing ought is the thing you should
be doing it's like an intriguing sound
so you should be intrigued when you see
a super fast moving everything which is
not nice for rocks so really they should
have given him a different name oh well
maybe he just flies really fat like the
boarding yeah I love looking outside my
favorite part of being alive who's gonna
run with wild horses I don't miss women
haha ways that him yeah I think so Auto
stuff you know is just another guy who
looks like him Oh God I'm just that
could be me you know acting back then
just seemed so much easier I might have
upset someone by saying that hey man you
gotta upset a few people to learn if
you're doing I just think I could do
this guy's job alright let's go back and
reshoot these scenes and just like
insert you in a name closes the iris all
the way man you got to remake this in
color with dialogue know you know
everything to make our worship but same
shots who wants to hear a bunch of
people talking you can go outside we
hear that no spur what to cuz it's a
movie I'm I will smoke my e-cigarette
from time to time guys I'm but only
directly into the camera yeah I mean
that would actually probably make it
spookier I've always dreamt of having
some kind of haunted house where the fog
machines are just VAP Bros it's like the
bass is really fast
hurry the Sun will soon be setting as
you can tell by this very dark title
cart I don't know this other emotion I'm
not happy I'm not full of radiant joy
[Laughter]
man there's a lot build oh yeah this is
a real time journey we will go no
further sir not for a fortune God all
the cliches come from this story yeah
real original nos erotic get a new idea
see plenty of other movies do the whole
we won't get paid to go further to it's
above my pay grade the land of phantoms
I'm okay to walk on foot I've seen the
Phantom but yeah it is kind of
fascinating to think like all the noobs
have done this trope literally thousands
of times to a town some reason much
people live in a town that no one should
be living in apparently oh where are
these quotes coming from who's saying
these God
oh that's from this movie all right what
that establishing shot of the tower
there I've seen that as a gif a million
times on online for whatever reason
damn you know another creepy-looking
dude he can't be out in the Sun yeah
he's very covered whoa whoa good
Oh God never traveled this festival whoa
was that it inverted shot climb it is
that a real path I was drawing I never
know Dan knew the horses are covered
- pretty nananana
[Music]
[Music]
what are these people he has working for
him children of the night daytime right
now or nighttime as if the Sun would go
down yeah I feel like there's still some
Sun but I could be wrong
see some old movies will do they do
something we're label all like tint the
film so you can tell like nighttime will
be blue yeah I mean it makes sense that
these guys are out in the night yeah as
I am
you're late young man it does almost
mean nowadays very much night retire I
was wildly confused for a second like
it's broad daylight what are they doing
out here yeah
day for night is not a technique that
had been perfected like black and white
no me tell we just got to make sure you
can see this stuff okay oh wow he's
creepy
yeah who played him Mex wreck nice wreck
the ceiling rule he's done that's a good
question that's a very rude way to cut
that
he is so hot do you go thinking about
that gay stuff again yeah I shouldn't do
that in this time period a lot of
trouble oh no maybe that's why he always
kisses her that same big showy way yeah
see I like this I'm not gay yeah I'm
acceptable for these times good play no
blood the your delicious blood but but
but but it's got here there's no there's
no build-up to this yeah what you said
that I'm just gonna go upstairs and
sleep but he has a girlfriend
he's not bleeding anymore you can't let
him be sucking on his finger that's let
those chat together a moment my friend
there are still several hours until dawn
and I have the whole day to sleep
see how I wonder where vampire lore
would have been at the time that this
took place because now you can't be like
stupid you should know you know
as the Sun rose Harker felt himself
freed from the oppressions of the night
he's dead too and he was wrong to feel
that way he let him live for now thus
for now now Roger hey Todd oh you over
there hey Todd oh what a beautiful day
how much I love the morning yeah this
really is the best time to be alive go
to gym drive to work then listen to a
podcast on the way my brain is so
trained anytime I see somebody looking
at like a square palm shaped thing I'm
like phone I guess you get tells day
time by how much wider his clothes are
yeah Wow they're just feasting all the
time his ostrich of cooking yeah he's a
chef that's why where's the Hat chef
it's like Halloween version of Chef
Boyardee I've had this it's amazing what
freezing things can do I think only the
wine is okay yeah the only the things
that get better with age
you know pour what's a bet I was
thinking I should get the [ __ ] out of
here
yeah but the morning is beautiful really
should change yeah I hope we brought one
pair of clothes Nina my beloved don't be
unhappy though I am far away I love you
this is a strange country amazing what
letters done I gave to if the text
content pops up on screen is small is
like brief O'Dare but after my first
night in this castle I found two large
bites on my neck from mosquitoes from
spiders made this into a comedy I was
overly optimistic protagonist I have had
some frightful dreams but they were only
dreams you mustn't worry about me
ain't nothing back I feel like yeah if
you just put like a wacky sound like
john c reilly playing this guy like he's
just so positive and optimistic no
matter what now that's a broad comedy i
would actually like to see happen if I
could get an Oscar ah - with the chassis
right I was almost attacked after I cut
myself on my thumb this is on my neck
this is what the townspeople warned me
about but it's okay I'm gonna be alright
yeah but don't worry about me it is I
still love you oh it's dusk already as
Twilight came on the empty Castle became
alive with menacing shadows
I can't do this while you're watching me
what's that I think it's a picture
mirror so I think it's a photo of Nina
dude you landed that oh [ __ ] is this
your wife
what a lovely throw this is the vampire
equivalent of like know you had it in
you that old mansion seems quite
satisfactory we shall be neighbors I
think actually that is the in shadow of
the vampire I think they cover this
scene and he says like she has a nice
bosom or something like that which could
be fabricated but whoa hmm
shift this is how man masturbated back
in those movies just thinking a lot
about and feeling euphoric
non-structured drinks the blood of the
young the blood necessary to his own
existence huh what a funny book I'm glad
I brought some fiction to distract me
during this business deal one can
recognize the mark of the vampire the
trace of his fangs on the victims throat
his throat was it been in though right I
said he had bites but that was on his
neck Oh unless they were like a little
bit more broad about with throat man
back then maybe maybe it's just like
anything adjacent to here yeah like if
they considered here
you do you never see a vampire bite just
right here yeah huh that was a head
audience put your head back never seen a
bald person who's gotta be I like a
remake Taz made into low-budget remake
he can't see me under here emitted Li
that is still very creepy not not with
the devil then yeah no I like Nosferatu
himself is yeah yeah he's very creepy
yeah yeah it was a big part of why this
movie like holds up still is it does
like at same night in Bremen in a
somnambulistic dream wow people were
required to be a lot smarter back then
some nebulous never even heard that word
I'd be sleepwalker because an ambulatory
things relate to emotion and mobility
military yeah and Sambas comes from like
is asleep you know like insomnia and
stuff like that Nina Nina forever
oh damn how she show up there the doctor
quickly
oh is this her home yeah oh okay don't
worry Nina I still love you I could have
ran away from Count Dracula many times I
could have paid attention to this book
I've been reading the whole time just
letting it happen
I think he's out I got so frightened
Jonathan Jonathan hear me I'm gonna do
this as slow as possible to give you
every chance to wake up
now this guy gets so rich what the hell
so I imagine this is what drackett was
actually supposed to look like in the
book you know I'm curious but maybe some
sexy [ __ ] hey suave dude Naraku
ah
where do they live they just get a
doctor there no the doctor laid Nina's
trance to some unknown disease since
then I've learned that she has sense the
Menace of Nosferatu that very night and
Harker far away had heard her cry of
warning so we should do our subtitles
and text please put the words on the
side to make people think a little bit I
really should change you get some of
this character arc is about how he wakes
up yeah happy today my morning [ __ ]
your first warning sign should have been
everything when he tried to kill you
bleeding a little bit
anytime anybody says your precious blood
yeah talks about your wife's throat I
mean whenever people talk about my
girlfriend's throat I'm just like she
does have a nice throat appreciate that
why do you know it is something as
specific as that wonder what you think
about her throat we're doing with it but
yeah I like throats wonder if Nosferatu
has like vampire friends who he goes
back to his legs so the whole throat
thinking you didn't even notice the
whites aren't everything
cats do is amusing because the lights
aren't on children network
[Laughter]
you done with your camera
duel
now I richest to take that as it's being
sped up or really supposed to take it as
he's moving that quickly oh yeah I've
taken it as he's moving that quickly and
doing disembodied things he's moving
that quickly yeah oh my god hey I feel
like that's a part of vampire Lauren
generals they can move like unnaturally
fast and this was probably the best way
to do that so hey Twilight got one thing
cannon oh when he like moves like saves
about 2 seconds by opening the door for
Bella yeah exactly
I've seldom seen one of those like super
fast running effects be really good yeah
not to show him you know obvious
limitations but like these days at least
okay so he's trying to get away now if
he's following the safety cats for
rewriting look we're at the midpoint
funny games the men little suspected
terrible what terrible karma they were
carrying down the valley oh he's trying
to get to Nina yeah oh dude yeah that's
what closed the deal is he saw Nina's
pictures like yeah I'll move in this is
visual storytelling some peasants
brought him here last evening he still
has a high fever copper knock it off
coffins coffins filled with earth people
smoke or too much poetry back then this
is how you get ahead in America you talk
to rec
cutback boy yeah I get it you've read a
lot you're literate at this time in
history I don't know what coffins filled
with earth me the [ __ ] are you so scared
of who that just sounds like a good way
to transport a lot of dirt yeah all
right you got a lot of dirt in your
coffin it's perfectly common I imagine
yeah cover a coffin with dirt that's how
they work I've actually always found
that to be a pretty cool part of vampire
lore that's sort of like if you get
earth then you can transport them you
know because I think there's yeah some
kind of trope about how vampires can't
leave land oh really I didn't know that
oh yeah there's something to there's
something to the dirt thing where it's
like yeah in order to travel they got to
have you know like you know earth with
them somehow was this like our first
introduction into a vampire not in
folklore but maybe in the cinema cinema
yeah I feel like it might be there there
may be like a short or something that
would have preceded this but Nosferatu
was enroute and with him disaster
approached Bremen at the same time dr.
van Helsing played by Hugh Jackman was
giving a course on the secrets of nature
and their strange correspondences to
human life dr. van Helsing yeah the
professor told his students about the
existence of a carnivorous plant an
arrestee van helsing show but something
I always expected to be an action hero
because that was my introduction to Hugh
Jackman movies but every time I see him
is something else he's just a doctor
like a big beard yeah like those crazy
mustache
my bosses Hugh Jackman virgins a little
cooler I really understood Marc I still
think that's a good like a decent idea
that's a movie I would like to see a
reboot for natural hunter yeah I feel
like that could have worked in a better
movie astonishing isn't it gentlemen
the plant is the vampire of the
vegetable kingdom
Nosferatu held a Renfield under his
influence from afar ooh
nos drunk whoa Charlie Chaplin patient
was brought in yesterday he's got out of
his mind
it's not the same doctor who was with
Nina is it yeah like it would have been
yeah that's the thing about these old
movies you gotta really pay attention
ever his face especially with all those
beards float
score no blood lad what step over there
mean mugging dude
Danny DeVito has really stood the test
of time
amazing how many actors got their start
in this man yeah all playing this one
guy and now gentlemen here's another
type of vampire a polyp with clothes
the first movie to use CGI haha what
Star Trek the Wrath of Khan transparent
that substance almost a phantom
coincidence
hey I'm smart I'm smug look good spider
spiders spiders it's a spider he's
replacing you let's measure you Nina was
often seen alone among the dude what the
flip was grandma doing at the sand dunes
watching and waiting for her husband's
already turned you know what we need
some dunes dunes yeah we have more dunes
I might know what a dude I've heard that
word many a time I was a sci-fi work yes
that movie the David Lynch directed that
wasn't a great adaptation of that's a
real thought dude was a thing DeRozan
actual thing yeah oh yeah Platinum Dunes
or the now-defunct Rat Pack d'un are
these like people buried by the sea
these are crosses I have had some
frightful dreams that they were only
dreams and mustn't worry of having oh
good this information is very accurate
and probably hasn't deflected the last
couple days since he actually wrote this
letter oh damn
did he just write like a few sentences
on one sheet of paper and just be like
all right next sheet I don't want to
fill this up too much here's the ink
leaked everyone seemed to have longer
hair back
[Music]
see becoming a vampire yeah thanks I
think yeah he's either becoming a
vampire or Joker going mad but I think
cuz the bite I believe he is becoming a
vampire feel like sometimes I get
details of this movie mixed up with
details from Dracula cuz Renfield is
kind of a different character in Dracula
hmm okay so NOS ratu's not his name then
is the type of vampire yeah dude I oh
yeah get all that dust Oh officer sweep
once you have the cleanest cell possible
we treat our prisoners right turn your
back towards the prisoner Oh knock knock
the devil in the Black Sea
I like this because whenever text comes
up on screen I never worry if I'm gonna
have enough time to read it
yeah that's nowadays every movie I'm
just like oh god I'm having to read it I
read better read this before this makes
me want to make a sigh I've made a
silent movie once it was a lot of fun
and this makes me want to do that a bit
make it a Saw movie sounds like it would
be the easiest thing in the world then
you actually do it you're like more
challenging I thought in ways yeah in
some ways yes and in some ways like
there's so many fun if you want to get
like wacky with it you know it's easy to
do that that is a pair of sideburns
aboard the Demeter first one man was
stricken then all what dared the
original logan's in this movie still got
the bone cause probably this is just the
Morbius or how story that house thing we
essentially got was Wolverine is oh yeah
just with us like swirly knife instead
of claws those guys not know how to deal
with being a vampire
this was so comfortable to travel by sea
hack then oh yeah oh I bet like after
sir
woohoo oh I forgot about that the
director this one was like do you go
check out this iMovie effect program on
my computer computer he's a witch one
evening at sundown the captain and his
first mate buried the last man of the
crew
hey props to that guy though for
sticking it out so your best crewman
right except the first mate yeah he's
Catholic I thought Jesus was born in
1945 this predates him by a whole like
10 years 12 years was this 33 I should
know I'm going below I want to have a
look in the hold my voice I always
become 10 yeah I have no idea just gonna
pick different characters from different
shows my feelings for you have a change
play grads oh man all these rats were
harmed in the making of this film
no no you got to aim at the hole where
the rats are coming out
why would that be your first resort dude
is really actually creepy like every
time he shows up on street it's like
whoa [ __ ] your [ __ ] creepy yeah there's
something I don't know the word for it
that's get just like just strikes you
right in the hardest yeah every shows up
there's something like uncanny and
otherworldly about him and and - cuz
like it is an old silent movie so like
everything is to a degree pretty real
it's nighttime just bright notice a very
bright sky for anything I never know
what time of day it is until I see him
step outside early test screenings that
was the main note they got FW Murnau
despite all sorts of obstacles hacker
pushed on towards Bremen meanwhile the
vampire the vessel move rapidly towards
the baltic pasture where they on the
same boat yeah oh damn I think they're
like Nosferatu just got a hair or lock
just got a head start you know he put
himself on the boat first the ship I
should say not a boat wish ever sent a
cut back to Nina she was just like
B I know I bet like the early uh you
know feedback cards of the test
screening you know Murnau sitting there
being like look we've only been making
these for like ten years now okay we'll
figure out nighttime later look at we
could even have a movie for this you
want to go back to like a Nickelodeon or
say you're welcome to go stare at a
zoetrope for a while it's a great view
from the window
ya see Russia from my house I could just
see the copper hopper don't you even
think about it hopper
oh hey copper just walked your eye right
trees thought she was thinking a selfie
yeah any time this movement is out there
he's coming
I must go to meet him yes so what he has
like my control abilities to some type
of psychic connection he can make as
well maybe and maybe if he just fixate
Sonia he can glare from far away I guess
he's been doing this a long time yeah
when he meets up with the other vampires
like check it out I have heard this
chick I'm like 500 miles when you're
forever
no you skills only get better over time
for every old
climb that wall Oh God with load if you
broke out huh that easily
oh I had to do it out the window that
has no bars on it
we paid a lot for this ship we're gonna
show every frame a master is coming the
master is here this guy is definitely
like a it was like he's coming too you
know yeah you know what I made I says
you know what I mean do you know what I
mean messing up the Tomko he is back on
track broke the fourth wall there yeah
come back here you copper it's his eyes
to his eyes look so white and his
fingernails yeah and his messed up teeth
dude this cop is terrible he keeps
turning his back to him dude you're
setting yourself up to get attacked by a
prisoner if you do that man what's this
whoa I've longed to understand when I
strive to travel with the earth little
coffins recent discover that's a purse
preserve the diabolic power of a person
sleeping of the day the Sun okay hello
ground it wish every bird I've launched
I'd understand what now strive to travel
with it offers recently discovered that
to preserve their diabolic our vampires
were sleeping of the day in the same on
hallowed ground in which they have been
buried midoriya taking notes I think I
got it an awestruck she has asleep I'm
gonna be awake for this nighttime yeah
this isn't conspicuous at all
damn he's also strong yeah guys we tried
carrying a coffin
full of dirt magic they were a lot
cheaper back then
tuck okay they're like holy on the side
different kind of music oh yeah right
strings
check it out run it's broad daylight at
10:00 p.m. you can see pretty well I
really shouldn't have used all my really
fast disembodied moving skills to get on
the boat why you're safe for now okay
well it was so far for the job that map
did not make it look this far away I
hope they gave him the same speech when
they got to the harbor they're like we
won't take you any further than this we
bring you a guy no smart for that coffin
yeah what's the coffin dirt lot of dirt
Jonathan thank god you're safe now I
feel that I to that stage that's another
movie about a weak woman needed to be
dependent on a man to feel safe you know
cinema never changes
yeah man way to be progressive [ __ ] this
movie
yes movies that pass the Bechdel test
rides a boat like a skateboard that is
pretty badass just like floating holding
a coffin yeah what what you're moving
either way oh forgot about that those
are especially for them those are pretty
impressive you could have gone to them
earlier if you just put the coffin down
handle business oh oh it is right on the
throat damn to the jugular veins maybe
run further inward yeah thanks guys dead
yeah I don't think so his pockets are so
full oh let's take off his suspenders
she never died with your pants on
and the scientists sing a living so on
board a lot of dead bodies though a
whole lot of dead bodies
alright let's move on
sometimes it happens on the high seas
another boat sailing for weeks and
months on end
you've
cheapest special effect there is what a
dead body he needs the power of
suggestion
hey this book has a Tall Ships log
Barma to Bremen oh the Dardanelles to
the mountains of Peru hmm interesting
doesn't say why he's dead you gotta
write that down this does sound like
Boat activity missing this chair for
many hours today
I wonder if it's hot or cold nice the
old-time people I'm like all those
layers man and you know that's not
breathable stuff it's a shame we don't
work cloaks anymore rounded Cape of an
Instagram I'm the strongest is sick Cruz
Restless uneasy made reportedly stowaway
hidin below Doc's will investigate
doesn't sound like porn of me test
chicken Walter panic on board three men
dead already
made out of his mind rats in the hold I
feared the plague
Wow
what do you thinks gonna happen next
knock knock with the devilís they must
have been very slow readers back let me
read all two of those sentences for
myself
no there's holes and their throats the
plague is here gushing blood no it's the
plague precious blood
ring around the roses Rosie's hang
around the Rosie pocket full of what
posies ashes ashes we all fall down sick
song isn't it
yeah dude the stirring song when you
think about it wait you're the remix and
then it's disturbing cuz of what it's
about
yeah there's a there are a lot of like
things from childhood that are cute and
then you hear the origin you're like ooh
notice look at me yeah to halt the
spread of the plague the burgomaster of
Bremen for business citizens of the city
to bring their sick to the well we're
just missing out on a whole plot point
here I don't think we're gonna get that
word hospitals loom on this for 30 more
[Music]
second
I like to think of this what Murnau was
the most anal about in the editing room
no must have longer titles look I gotta
pass this message out everywhere about
the play but I'm not gonna protect
myself now let's rock I'm gonna hit this
drums without wearing a mask
hey this will keep the plague away
that's just what they believe back then
man yeah pestilence cuz moses dealt with
a play - yeah and so did brendan fraiser
in the mummy a whole bunch of them it's
even more impressive
I can't draw a cross on your window I'm
sorry it's not how chalk works this is
for the movies about now this is about
the plague oh don't do that and make him
carry himself I feel like we switched
movies kinda yeah it seems like it
turned into people finding dead bodies
on a boat now they think the plagues
here and it's about them dealing with
the plague yeah
never open the book of the vampires too
much keep the book of the vampires
around now it's gonna become evil the
vampires wrath feel like this is a
plague things like a logical place mean
it looks like a man
hey man for the time smoking dude yeah
guys 14 minutes left this movie knowing
credits for silent films it's like the
last 10 minutes of problems right there
oh yeah just a minute long cuz this
movie just starts right yet so I'm
trying to think is yeah you could you
trace like only a woman can break his
fried fools but I'm a vampire wrote this
book that's why a woman pure in heart
who will offer her blood freely to
Nosferatu
and but I'm a woman that looks like a
man is my blood good enough what do I
have too much man DNA Oh keep the
vampire by her side until after the
[Laughter]
cartoons are pigs yeah I know I will get
the more ladies we will put this in the
book if they want or a [ __ ] to go away
they gotta get married to us
mr. blood look every night in front of
me
what who Oh God there are buildings out
there he's not there
damnit woo okay this is a nice shot yeah
let's Cheers the first time made clear
it's night time just from the actual
imagery yeah good good there's not much
town all right
townspeople either the titles are in
night time townspeople lived in mortal
terror who was sick or dying who will be
stricken tomorrow disease of the future
hey it's David Thewlis that same guy
David Thewlis from wonderful no no no is
that is that when they're gonna be smart
on question about my man through this
David Thewlis I learned his name when I
found out he was playing really does be
like a pedophile he does he's an odd
looking guy yeah although there's that's
a good there's a guy in my in my
girlfriend's building who is on one of
those you know sexual assault sites sex
offender sites oh boy he's like massive
it looks like Jason Momoa what was his
offence underage porn for reals yeah
damn that but that is a he's a
registered sex offender now only a woman
can break his frightful spell
in pure and offer all right even though
the office is reread this let's keep it
on the screen for 35 more seconds this
is important the future will call this
exposition this is a visual storytelling
has its shortcomings escaped he
strangled his keeper they're both
talking about a man's he described this
man he had okay [ __ ] [ __ ] oh oh sorry
about the prisoner yeah ride felt yeah
no man they blew a great grandpappy of
the both of them after him I guess
blamed the plague on him or do they
think he's do they think he is uh
Dracula
oh maybe is this nighttime that's a
great question
he looks like mr. toad a little bit is
that you know from mr. Toad's Wild Ride
and whichever movie that comes from the
Willows I think go to Disneyland
to burst Jonathan and we're Shrek this
movies become about the plague and her
occasionally rereading the same
paragraph from that vampire book that's
great mislead I tripped over some ground
No
I would love to take like Transformers
Revenge of the Fallen and just time
travel and play it for the people this
is the future this is what it will all
become because not only it would be like
a super modern movie with talking but it
would be like what is everything I'm
only familiar with roads trees and
people the plague taking all my credit
No damn you gotta admit that man when
Dracula has a goal in mind he keeps his
auditory you could learn a lot about
success from Dracula yeah man he's
determined he's just like all right man
look saw this girl's throat and I had a
decision right then and there I'm gonna
go find this girl
and I'm gonna bite her throat I'm gonna
move land literally and see ya
that's dumb struggle come on dammit
is that yes we don't delete he's gonna
do the window trick where he's acting
like he's walking down next aisle he's
gonna do it in like 25 seconds yeah
the professor call the professor van
Helsing yeah
paying attention visual story time with
the occasional word to let you know most
fascinated by that how people were like
talkies will never get wrong dude why'd
you let Jonathan leave you
does she be manipulated John to me she's
like glamorized since I put the camera
back how much more crooked have I made
the look is that the famous shot that's
the shadow going up the wall you know
that one okay yeah it's one of the
favorite shots yeah that gets me after
one it was a cool shot I was more
impressed with the other one for some
reason
oh yeah well cuz like his fingers are
all yeah and that is clever use of
architecture
oh oh oh yeah I remember this new from
shadow of the vampire
yeah why it's really look for that yeah
if I actually I froze those images
really chilling the ones that are like
the contrast is high it's a you have to
kind of let your eyes find things Oh
dawn
I've been I says [ __ ] oh now go back
master master beware Sam's coming up
right now Jonathan took him off a long
time to get the professor for his
girlfriend Jonathan it's your favorite
time of day should we let him escape
Oh interesting
Oh thousands of years alive he never
learned his lessons yeah hey man Oh
check this effect of the night movie
dude bro chicks not worth it man
the master just take the Masters dad
masters day I was just holding down for
him
Jonathan
what is it my love yeah sorry it would
be sick salmon I forgot my doctor tools
and at that moment as if by a miracle
the sick no longer died and the stifling
shadow of the vampire vanished with the
Morning Sun hey that's where they got
the movie name
morning morning Sun yeah that song we're
gonna marathon guys it's one of the
Google next yeah all the classic oh wow
no credits even no credits back in the
DIA they needed a co-host credit scenes
yeah up the universe wears
Frankenstein's monster like that book
existed well switch back to the regular
came to talk about this alright guys
can't really talk for too long gotta go
catch a star is born
[Music]
well what I can tell you is that this
was a test of my patience haha you gotta
understand I have never seen a silent
movie before and I feel a couple of
feelings just in terms of that category
one I feel like I'm smarter culture yeah
because I started watching a more
classic films within the past year
because my laid is very much into those
and then now we're back to the silent
films and I felt like it was it looks
like I'm looking into a piece of history
yeah and obviously film history and
there's a lot to appreciate about the
hard work it must take to keep an
automat you back then it wasn't as
difficult raizy
yeah people are there they're not really
here it is a cool lesson in like visual
storytelling I think that
these are not the best of performances
obviously it has acting has evolved so
much yes that's one earmark of silence I
feel like I'm sure that there are
exceptions to the rule but yeah
everything is very expressive well you
got to be though yeah that's a
difference it was also really
interesting to see how much of very
popular horror movie tropes were
evidently borrowed from this and so many
capacities oh yeah yeah which I thought
was really interesting and this is
totally Dracula like no doubt this is a
cool story Matt Shrek
that's if there's one thing that stands
the test of time it is all this stuff a
Mack Shrek when he's it's called
Nosferatu he has the least screen time
out of anyone in this film yeah and he
is just so so well-liked it's so subtle
that it seems like it's from a like when
I think about shadow of the vampire how
the story to that even came to be like
the plot of the making of but what if he
was really that I could see how
someone's mind got there
yeah when I see this performance yeah
because it's like this doesn't even seem
like an actor this just seems like a
thing day yeah yeah he feels very
uncanny and yeah like some kind of feral
creature you know yeah like he really
does feel like a combination of a man
and a bat yeah he feels real yeah and
crazy fingers I'm not I'm not
well-versed enough to properly break
down into how a silent film performance
is very effective everyone else was
amusing he was affected have a president
yeah yeah he has so much and I even
appreciate it like you know it seems
like a lot of other horror movie true
beyond the plot tropes even like the
shadow effects mmm the shadow of the
vampire given the shadow effects of him
being in frame and then like the claws
coming up and ever like there were some
really cool stuff that even to this day
I'm gonna seen it going that's pretty
cool and impressive though they figured
it out for that time oh yes especially
with those superimpositions where he'll
like show up and then yeah out and stuff
like for that time like that's quite
impressive yes and you know there's a
couple times it was towards the end
where I had a harder time paying
attention but for most of you time I
thought it was pretty simple to pay
attention to actually yeah like the
beginning part was amusing when he
actually shows to the castle was really
pulled in and then the the plague stuff
was kind of throwing me off I was like
this doesn't really fit for me and in
terms of the rest of the movie I'm sure
the right thing to say is everything's
perfect about this film no no no but
that's just not how I feel about that
moment and I was like you seem like you
just got so sidetracked into so story
yeah yeah it's like I feel like it makes
a lot of logical sense for the people to
jump to that community but a freak out
but but it is becomes like yeah I
thought the vampire show up to kill this
girl who works where's that plot yeah so
it's like it seems like the main plot
almost takes a background yeah everybody
figures out what to do it feels yeah but
John means so much to you um I mean
partly is just one of those you know
proto horror films that the first time I
saw it was probably even later on in
life and like I you know I grew up with
at least a certain amount of classic
cinema and I'd seen a couple silence but
I'm no means an expert but this is one
of those movies where even though parts
of it are definitely dated for sure it
still holds up to me and yeah just the
count is so uncanny and to this day is
just so chilling and I don't know I just
like the tambour of the story it's like
even watching him get out into you know
the countryside into the Phantom land
and all that like I think it has a lot
of atmosphere and and - it's like you
look at a movie this old it's like yeah
everything you know sets and paintings
and you know whatever else but it's all
very tangible yeah I know and and yeah
especially from you know like a
historical sample that's what I meant by
it looks hard to film and that
historical probable things are saying
because they had to really film all this
stuff and I'm sure for the time that it
was it's like this might look like you
shoot this a day no problem like this
today would be like like student
filmmakers would put this together yeah
but
but back then I'm sure there's a very
shy vampire of whatever first came out I
was a kid I don't remember that movie I
barely remember anything it goes on yeah
so I don't I don't even I mean that's
something I'm a true story that plays on
the myth and yeah really you know yeah
so I'm not going based off any of that
like just thinking about what the times
were like it must have been difficult to
assemble this film back then you know oh
yeah well especially I mean they have a
number you know by those standards they
have a number of effects shots so to
speak I mean you have all the sped up
moments to where he's like you know
making a coffin float and making doors
open and so I guess like things like
that really endeared me to this movie to
see like those early you know the
techniques use and why and I really
appreciate the way that they use the
vampire lore to I just feel like it has
just a ton of atmosphere so that yeah
like even though there are things that
are a bit you know big and that's kind
of humorous by today's standards you
know I still think that yeah this movie
just has like a quintessentially
especially like Halloween time like
horror film vibe you know it's crazy Max
Schreck is the name of Christopher
Walken's character and Batman Returns
which is a made-up character for Batman
Returns and he became a rather memorable
character of that fret and that specific
Batman franchise and then he went on to
play Max Schreck the vampire and shadow
of the vampire before yeah but even saw
walk in space thing is I've never
actually seen Batman Returns and that's
one of the things that or if I have it's
been a long time I can uh but I've seen
like snips but that's one of the things
where I'm like I want to sit down and
watch it because like I don't think
it'll be like hugely referential but
I've always found it fascinating that
yeah walking his max correct that was a
weird confusing visual moment I had
because I saw Christopher Walken and I
was like oh yeah max Shreck beverage
like it's like let's crazy there's an
actual photo I had to look it up for
myself I'm like okay yeah max rex an
actor like he's not just some like
creepy dude they found well that's the
other thing too about just old film is
there's so much noise that it makes
things look kind of real because you're
already staring they're a lot of chaff
Wow
that's faster than birthdays three days
after mine dude yeah I enjoyed it I'm
proud of myself for watching feel like I
read a book yeah yeah you get a gold
star
yeah Jan thanks for asking us to do this
you know I've never I've never watched
it and you know I needed a good excuse
and hopefully this question comes up in
the Schmoe down yeah what's the guy's
name who who's a character max wreck
it's a guys named Jonathan it's the
girls named Nina where's the last half
movie about the [ __ ] plague yeah
that's cool yeah that's cool this seems
like the kind of experience that will
grow on me yeah first like the more I
think about this film you know because
it's so different for my viewing
experience this is Miles like just so
incredibly different that to watch an
actual silent film is like wow this is
it's like a cold if I kind of film to me
you know a lot to absorb
well yeah cuz it's fascinating to look
at the you can see the evolution like
it's it's innately anthropological in a
sense because you can just tell how much
has changed I'm kind of pure and go okay
how would they have done this at the
time you know how they've approached all
this well Jan you stay sexy buddy
looking forward to hearing your feedback
yeah love you bud start the Halloween
season yeah